this world today so full of challenges
and opportunities challenges are such an
integral part of growth in our life we
always look to to be challenged
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world now I started the one
rule series because I see so many
different rules come up over and over
and over again in the top ten series
that I do and I thought hey let's mash
up all the rules that keep coming up
consistently into one video and so today
we're going to talk about how you can
take on challenges enjoy
[Music]
this world today's of full of challenges
and opportunities 2,000 years ago full
of challenges and opportunities and I'm
sure 2,000 years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there's always it depends on how you
look at somebody look at this challenge
as opportunity young people always say
there's no opportunity I complain a lot
when I was young because I think Bill
Gates took odd opportunities for the
Microsoft Steve Jobs all these guys
there's no job there's no great big
stuff left for us but I think
opportunity always lies in the
challenges always lies in the complaints
if you can solve the challenge you have
there you will be successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem of the big opportunity you have
when I injured my Achilles and it became
something worse okay this is this is the
end of my career could be now so since I
was 21 years old and thinking okay I
have to figure out what comes next
you kind of brainstorm uid aid but you
never really executed it and when the
injury happened is I don't know I needed
to start building now right and that's
when the turning point was for me but
I'm sitting there and I have the
Achilles injury it's one thing to sit
there and try to block out the
frustrations of being injured because
that's you're constantly tugging but
that right as opposed to simply
replacing that with a new challenge
that's something that gets you excited
so now you're not focused on not being
depressed you're focused on the
excitement of building something and so
it was extremely exciting man having to
figure something out and build it from
the ground up there's a lot of young
actors and musicians today they they
kind of spin out of control a little bit
why are you so good at just like making
your career is amazing and you're just
making the right decisions
another thing here's a really that's
really nice to hear I guess I just I've
just been really lucky in a sense that
I've been offered a really diverse and
interesting range of roles and I've just
tried to do things that slightly terrify
me every time I guess I mean most almost
every project I've done since Harry
Potter I've I felt really really scared
to start so I've just kept trying to
challenge myself really
I play Nicki in The Bling Ring and how
perfectly Nicki Nicki like yoga and
cheese cleanses and she teaches pole
dancing she's this very complex girl and
character style that she was kind of
boyish kind of a tease and it's kind of
like nothing I've done before to
research the part I learnt pole dance I
watched a lot of reality television I
did yoga I did a lot of thinking about
how you'd get into the mindset why you
would think that stealing is okay it was
really important to me that I felt like
I understood her and I could relate to
her and she felt like a real person
I feel challenges are such an integral
part of growth in our life for example a
teacher will always pose higher and
higher challenges to the students why
because the teacher wants the student to
grow in his or her understanding of the
subject mathematics for instance what's
mathematics in kindergarten and primary
school in secondary school in university
is different why because the challenge
level goes on increasing and the higher
the challenge and in a better way we are
able to crack it
we simply grow deeper in our
understanding of the subject there is no
meaning to life without a challenge and
the symptom of greatness is to accept
that challenge in a very sportive spirit
and
how to grow deeper in whatever we are
doing
I always did everything back as half
words you know I like to challenge
myself and I went to Mount Lebanon High
School in Pittsburgh and I wanted to
take business classes my junior year
only they didn't offer any business
classes and so I decided I'd take some
college business classes but University
of Pittsburgh didn't offer any real
business classes either so I said you
know I'm gonna challenge myself and so I
took a couple night classes at the
University of Pittsburgh my junior year
in high school did well in them and
didn't wasn't really challenged all that
much at all and so I just dropped out of
high school and instead of going back
for my senior year I went that went to
the University of Pittsburgh and started
taking classes there and like my buddies
were like where'd you go and it just I
just I've always tried to challenge
myself I could have dropped my album any
time I'm fully loaded
I'm war already at all times I have so
many records that in my Drive trust me
anybody act up I'll let one go now
listen the reason why I took longer than
I usually do I did it on purpose I'm
tired of dinosaurs I'm tired of way
people do roll out some rules and
regulations I never followed a rule of
regulation the door has never been open
for me to walk in and my whole career
why I'm gonna follow any type of
protocol
I'll never was accepted like that I was
determined passionately ripped doors
down took the hinges off and put the
hinges in the boys hands when they try
to stop DJ coward
so what I did was I put out more hit
records I challenged radio I challenged
the game I only I've said it a few times
I only want to play characters that are
gonna challenge me and make me scared
because that's when I feel I would be
doing the best work you know if I feel
like okay this is really something
that's scary to me
then that's what I should be doing you
know it's just doing the same thing and
not getting any better
why Sicario and why the perfect
usually first of all I love what I do
and you have to love what you do
otherwise do something else usually is
the story and then the character you
know the like in a perfect day the
character is a little bit different it's
very different from the Sicario
character so we as actors we always look
to to be challenged to try something
different
to try different characters and so those
two are different and you know it's if
it wasn't the money I wish I could say
was the money but it wasn't the money I
think we're gonna always have these
moments in our lives where an
opportunity comes that we're not quite
ready for yet and that's when it's easy
to say no I'm not ready I don't the
experience they don't the confidence I
have the courage and you have all these
limiting self beliefs that come into
play and you tell you some all the
reasons why you can't go and do
something and those are the changes that
you have the opportunity to step up and
kind of rise to the next level right
because there's always new opportunities
coming at you I think even Rosanna of
looking at her coming on today it wasn't
supposed to be Rosanna here with me
today was supposed to be her boyfriend
Alex who helps me run this studio at
Ronald and salsa he's sick puking and
just lying down in bed and I said
Rosanna why don't you come out today and
help me with the videos and she's never
been on our YouTube channel before and
was nervous and scared but said I'm
gonna do it and so it's not about not
being nervous not being scared but it's
about feeling it absorbing it and still
doing it anyway because it's through
those moments it's gonna have
significant growth you know this is the
thing that I always want to do when I'm
writing songs is challenge myself you
know I don't you know I don't want to
turn myself into the bum-out King you
know or or just be the guy who's
constantly trying to be emotive you know
you know I want to you know try and do
new things because that shakes it up and
it gets you out of that comfort zone
now I've got a special bonus clip with
Mary Barra that I think you're really
going to enjoy but before that my
question of the day today is I want to
know what is the biggest challenge that
you need to take on right now in your
business or in your life what is the
biggest challenge leaving the comments
below I'm excited to hear what you have
to say thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
address challenges head-on I'm reminded
of the plant manager who asked his lead
engineer to explain her hiring process
she said well I fill a bathtub with
water and offer the applicant a TSP a
tea cup and a bucket then we ask him or
her to empty the tub I get it the
manager said I'll go get her we'll use
the bucket no the engineers said a
go-getter will pull the drain plug if
you have an issue in your life at work
or at home pull the drain plug address
it head-on and with everything you have
address it right away in my experience
it's much better to get the right people
in a room make a plan and address that
challenge and remember hope is not a
strategy problems don't go away when you
ignore them they tend to get bigger
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people
passion and not one drop of most
self-worth depends on Europe that's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details